ja in meinem vortrag geht es über die
frage nach dem gefühl status und dem
trieb status bezüglich cantz theorie der
achtung und zwar anhand von ludwig
heinrich jakob und wer gottlieb fichte
zunächst zur gliederung meines vortrags
er hat wird erst was allgemein sagen zur
frage nach der achtung als emotion wer
etwas zum philosophischen begriff der
emotionen zurück glaube dadurch mehr
aufschluss über diese sehr schwierige
theorie der achtung bei kann zu finden
dann werde ich kann's theorie der
achtung vor dem hintergrund als
emotionen interpretiert aber ein viele
verschiedene problematiken aufwirft
gerade für die darauf folgende debatte
dann wenn die ich mich ludwig heinrich
nach kopps theorie der achtung als
gefühl zu im gegensatz zur emotion ich
werde zwischen strengen entscheiden
im vierten teil gehe ich auf sicht ist
theorie der achtung als trieb ein und
abschließend werde ich fazit ziehen und
schauen inwiefern diese jeweiligen
interpretation oder rekonstruktion der
achtung inwiefern sie gerecht werden der
kantischen theorie ja zunächst zur frage
macht der emotionen der dem emotionalen
status von achtung
ich beziehe mich jetzt hier auf einen
neueren texten der stamford enzyklopädie
auf los wenn ich immer die mal sehr sehr
wichtig findet diese artikel
und da heißt es in motions historical
wie im konzept race experience ist
second es über jacksons moderations das
ist dieser beitrag in motion von 1km
kino und das sag ich finde es sehr
interessant also historisch wurden
emotionen als erfahrung phänomenale
gehalte als er variation oder urteil mit
könnte auch sagen vielleicht etwas
kognitives proposition ahl
und drittens als motivationen
triebfedern beweggründe behandelt und
ich glaube dass man jetzt in diesem
sinne emotionen systematisch streng
unterscheiden kann
von verwandten phänomenen wie gefühlen
effekten und stimmungen ich möchte auch
nicht weiter eingehen nur so viel sagen
ich glaube wir sollten streng
unterscheiden zwischen emotionen und
gefühle und zwar insofern als emotionen
ein viel komplexeres phänomen sind sie
erzählt wie ich sagen würde sie haben
ein integraler subjektivität im team
zeigt sich die subjektivität vollständig
ganzheitlich das ganze objekt dritter in
hervor
nicht nur partiell wie im gefühl des
hungers oder in einer stimmung
sie sind aber im gegensatz zum effekt in
meinen augen auch das subjekt ganz
robust und nicht nur momentan der effekt
fliegt verfliegt beachtung aber bleibt
und hat deswegen ihr was von einer
einstellung bringe als beispiel der
evolution die achtung finde ich ist ein
paradefall der emotionen gegensatz zum
hunger ein gefühl ist so gut die ein
effekt darstellt und zum glück trauer
die eine stimmung dann stimmt dass
mehrere vorschlag zur unterscheidung und
wir können jetzt hier verschiedene
parallelen sehen von zwischen achtung
und wut zwischen emotionen effekt sie
sind ideal zu treffen uns ganz deswegen
motivieren sie uns auch so gut
stimmungen und gefühle motivieren uns
nicht so gut wie emotionen und affekte
ist meine these aber im gegensatz zum
effekt hat die emotion noch etwas
robuster receiver flieht nicht einfach
und diese robustheit der emotion setzt
uns in die lage zu reflektieren also in
der emotion sind immer auch rational im
moment enthalten die im affekt nicht so
sehr enthalten sind weswegen wir häufig
auch im effekt dinge tun die wir
hinterher bereuen und deswegen und deren
wegen wir vielleicht sogar gar nicht
ganz zur verantwortung gezogen werden
etwas nervig tun dass wir alles wissen
nicht ganz beherrscht
in einer emotion so meine these sind wir
und beherrscht weil sie eben robust ist
und deswegen auch kontrollierbar ist
vor diesem hintergrund der emotion wie
ich sie verstehen möchte ich mir jetzt
kann's theorie der achtung zu wenden sie
ist eine komplexe emotion die erstens
einen phänomenalen gehalt besitzt also
diese emotions es feelings eine
proportionale struktur besitzt also das
ist die evaluations und eine motivation
kraft besitzt also wenn wir kann's
theorie beachtung als emotionen
verstehen können wir diese drei aspekte
in sich vereinen
und das möchte ich jetzt kurz anhand von
verschiedenen beispielen tun also zum
zur frage nach der achtung als
phänomenale erfahrung als gefühl gibt es
folgendes zitat kann sagt achtung ist
eine empfindung welche aber nicht vor
der gesetzgebung der praxis fünfte
vorher gehen soll definiert durch
dieselbe allein und zwar als ein zwang
grip sein empfinden
ferner achtung ist einerseits bloß
negativ andererseits und zwar in
ansehung des einschränkenden grundes
direkt positiv kann zeigt auch in der
achtung mit der eigentlichen
niedergeschlagen wird spüren wir so was
ein schmerz und wir machen das buchen
gerne zu einem unwille das ist durchaus
eine phänomenale seiten gefühlsmäßige
sei aber eben nicht die einzige es würde
zu kurz greifen
es gibt noch eine zweite dimension
achtung als evaluation als urteil oder
als eine große soziale struktur
das sagte vorn ist das bewusstsein der
frei unterwerfung des willens oder das
gesetz als mit einem vermeintlichen
zwang die alle neigung aber nur durch
eigenschaft angetastet verbunden ist nun
die acht und fürst gesetz also das
bewusstsein ist ein bewusstes strukturen
und hier haben wir noch mal deutlich
dass moralische gesetz ist zitat für
sich selbst in teile der vernunft trieb
viele fehler
also ich habe mir das urteilen
achtung hat immer auch was urteil zum
mäßiges auch wenn sie bekannt immer auf
sagt nicht die distanz zur beurteilung
ist das ist die vernunft aber es hat
etwas damit zu tun
darauf müssen wir gleich noch näher
eingehen und drittens achtung als
motivation
achtung ist wie kann sagt die einzige
und zugleich und bezweifelte moralische
triebfeder
achtung ist die sinnlichkeit selbst
subjektiv als triebfeder betrachtet eine
gute kann man sagen
und gibt es einen unterschied einmal
sagte sie ist die unbezahlte betrieb
würde und sagt nun sie ist betrachtet
als dennoch finde ich haben wir hier
auch dieses moment der motivation in der
emotion der achtung bewahren so und
jetzt ist meine these dass da kommen
fichte auf jeweils verschiedene art
einen aspekt der komplexen emotionen
beachtung nach kant ins zentrum ihrer
betrachtung stellt und analysieren
jakob nimmt den phänomenalen gehalt der
achtung als vernünftiges gefühl in den
blickdichten nimmt hingegen stärker den
motivationen gehalt beachtung in den
blick der als sittlichen trieb dann
interpretiert so jetzt erst zu jacobs
theorie der achtung als gefühl das hat
der gute mann aus ist recht unbekannt
und ich möchte in diesem zusammenhang
auf seine schrift verweisen über das
moralische gefühl ein schmales büchlein
aus den ersten 88
das ist mittlerweile als transkription
zum herunterladen auf unserer seite www
freiheit moral politik.de / materialien
und dann im unterbereich dateien zum
herunterladen verfügbar können sie sich
gerne unterlagen die ich schicke ihm
nachher im chat auch noch die genaue
angabe kunden in beschreibung suite dann
auch den kindern so jetzt zu einem zitat
von jakob darunter der unendlichen zahl
derer dinge die sich unsere blicke immer
mehr und mehr zu entziehen scheint die
weiter wir sie verfolgen und die dennoch
reizt genug behalten
den forscher in unabhängige weise mit
sich vor zu reisen trifft man auch die
gefühle an
es ist wohl nie daran zu denken ihre
natur zu ergründen aber die zwecke der
selben aufzusuchen ihre weise teilung zu
bewundern die großen absichten
kennenzulernen die durch tiefen führt
wird bemerken die sie das mittel sind
wir durch eine lebendige wesen tätigkeit
gesetzt werden und wie selbst vernunft
und verstand ohne sie note kräfte in
unserer natur sein würden alle gefühle
und jetzt kommende kommt eine
klassifikation alle gefühle zerteilt
sich überhaupt lassen die voneinander
der ursprung nach wesentlich
verschiedensten sind nämlich entweder
sinnlich oder vernünftigen gefühle
sinnliche nämlich all diejenigen welche
durch die bedürfnisse des sinnlichen
natur bewirkt werden als hunger schmerz
wohl sein und so weiter eine sinnliche
natur ist sind auch diese gefühle wir
haben sie also mit den tieren gemein
vernünftige gefühle auf der anderen
seite sind solche welche bloß durch die
wirkung des verstandes und der vernunft
in einer sinnlichen natur möglichst sie
haben unstreitig auch in der
sinnlichkeit des menschen ihren sitz
bedürften aber einer ganz eine
kausalität die sich bei den tieren nicht
findet daher sie auch bei diesen gar
nicht angetroffen werden können dem die
sinnlichen werden durch befriedigung
nicht befriedigung der bedürfnisse von
fremden kräften erzeugt die vernünftigen
aber bewirken wir durch eigene
selbsttätige kraft nur ein zitat jetzt
gibt es nämlich auch noch gemischte
gefühle also nicht nur sinnliche und
vernünftiges gibt noch eine dritte
klasse
es gibt auch gefühle welche teils durch
einfluss empfangen teils durch vernunft
gewirkt oder modifiziert sind zb das
mitgefühlt das nicht bloß durch die
sympathische rührung der gleich
bestimmten zeiten unsere empfindungen
werkzeuge und zugleich durch überlegung
hervorgebracht diese art der gefühle
möchte ich vermischten
da sie aber keinen besonderen ursprung
haben zu einer untersuchung der selben
auf beide quellen gesehen und von jeder
ihre eigentümliches abgeleitet
so können sie hier als abgeleitet
betrachtet werden und jetzt
unterscheidet er die vernünftigen
gefühle weiter die vernünftigen gefühle
kann man in theoretische und praktische
vernünftige ein theoretischer wenn sie
ihre wirkung des verstandes der
theoretischen verknüpft sind.die beifall
überzeugung gewissheit usw
praktische die mit der erkenntnis der
gesetze die unsere handlungen bestimmen
können das heißt mit der praktischen
vernunft in verbindung stehen und
handlung möglich machen so jetzt haben
wir hier sehr viel information bekommen
klassifikation ich möchte es jetzt mal
trafen schon hand eines diagramms mehr
verdeutlichen also gefühle
die können unterscheiden sinnliche der
sagte hunger oder finanz und wir können
sie in vernünftige und hier führt er als
beispiel lieber gleich noch sehen werden
so dass mit zustimmung und beifall an
und noch vermischte dazu würde das
mitgefühl dienen die vernünftigen können
wir jetzt aber eben weiter unterhalten
noch einmal die theoretische benötige
gefühle das bezeugung gewissheit und
praktische und auf diese folgen mehr
einzugehen seien nämlich dann ente
achtung und verachtung das ist die
übersicht bei jako
so und jetzt vertritt der complete asse
dass gefühle keine kognitive bzw
proposition aale struktur haben das
urteil ist ganz und gar keine funktion
der gefühle
man kann weder deutlich einer
undeutliche urteile vermittelt der sehr
empfehlen ein wahrheits und schönheits
gefühl und so weiter sind ebensolche
unding wenn sie nicht gefühle bedeuten
die mit der erkenntnis dass warm und
schön verbunden sind sondern selbst
vermögen sein sollen über das wahre und
schöne zu urteilen mit ihnen durch sie
die grundsätze des waren schön als
gegeben angesehen werden die gefühle
sind eine von erkenntnisvermögen ganz
verschiedene einrichtungen der natur die
zwar beurteilen begleiten aber nicht mit
ihm allein sind so also auch hier sagte
sind keine vermögen
also jedenfalls das wahre und schöne zu
beurteilen das muss die vernunft machen
aber sie bekleiden unsere urteile das
heißt wir können ist als ep phänomene
verstehen vielleicht also die
theoretische verrückt hat zur folge dass
theoretisch vernünftige gefühl und die
praktische vernunft hat zur folge dass
praktisch vernünftige gefühl weil die
praktisch wird immerhin sinnlichen wesen
eingebettet ist oder sich ihm findet wie
wir sind aber es sind nur folgen also
ich interpretiere sie als ep phänomene
aber nicht irgendwelche substanziellen
eigenschaften die fast wie ein vermögen
zur beurteilung von theoretischen
zerfallen oder praktischen verhalten
sind
achtung und verachtung sind jetzt nach
jakob gleichermaßen richtig gefühle
eines interessant kann sagt ja es gibt
nur ein einziges vernunft vernünftiges
gefühl für uns gewirkt das gefühl ist
die achtung der kopf entfernt sich
hiervon kann insofern er auch sagt es
geht auch die verachtung und ist genau
so vernünftig achtung ist ein gefühl
welches nur durch vernunft gewirkt
werden kann und auch nur mit der
erkenntnis von vernunft wirkung
verbunden ist
es geht auch nicht nur um den grund des
gefühls und auch um die der von nutzen
die folgen der vernunft mit dem das
gefühl verbunden wo ein vernünftiges
wesen vernunft in ihren wirkungen
entdeckte entsteht achtung gelehrsamkeit
untersuchungen welche ohne tiefsee-
nicht verbracht werden konnten jede
handlungen kurz alles wobei wir
voraussetzen dass es ohne die mitwirkung
der vernunft nicht zustande kommen
könnte flößt notwendig achtung ein
die erkenntnis des mangels der
vernünftigen gesetze oder des
widerstreit mit denselben erzeugt
verachtung ein gelehrter kann daher
meine achtung erregt haben wenn ich in
seinen schriften die stärke seiner ein
bekenntnis kraft oder den tief sind
seines geistes habe kennenlernen aber
sobald ich erfahre dass seine würfe die
starken ist seine handlung zu dirigieren
das letztere der vernunft wieder
strahlten vertritt eine tiefe verachtung
an die stelle der achtung nicht als ob
ich aufhörte die gelehrsamkeit zu achten
hier muss natürlich jetzt vorhersagen
jakob versteht die achtung und
missachtung in einem weiteren sinn als
kannte es tut kant reserviert wie wir
alle wissen achtung nur auf moralische
sachverhalte die also der reihe gott zu
wirst entspringen und hier scheint jetzt
jakob gesagt diesen begriff weiter zu
verwenden weil es hier auch um so was
wie tief sind gelehrsamkeit und so
weitergeht hat mich gleich an die stelle
aus der grundlegung zur metaphysik der
sitten erinnert wo kannte eigentlich
sagt so etwas nie witz und talente des
geistes die haben keine absoluten wert
für die trifft also gerade nicht die
acht zu jacob verwendet achtung jetzt in
einem weiteren sinne als auch dass die
bewunderung für eine starke vernünftig
jetzt aber nicht unbedingt gleich
moralisch zu verstehen sind balkan
hinzu kommt noch ein weiterer punkt das
nach jakob moralische gefühle
systemische park sind das moralische
gefühl kann also nie der letzte
gerichtshof sein auf welchen man sich
berufen könnte weil es selbst etwas
abgeleitet ist und erzeugt das ist wovon
man von einer scharfen untersuchen seine
echten abstimmung nicht mit gewissheit
sagen kann ob es nicht da ein bastard
sei denn die sinnlichkeit durch sich
selbst erzeugt und der vernunft
untergeschoben haben also wir können uns
nie direkt bei den prinzipien die
operation ist beim gerichtshof auf an
gefühle einlassen weil wir nie einen
kriterium dafür haben ob es nicht von
metronom in gründen verursacht sind also
das ist die interpretation der achtung
als gefühl und aber eben auch nicht als
evolution und ich glaube eben das kann's
die rieder achtung nicht treffend als
gefühlten als emotionen verstanden
werden muss
jetzt komme ich zum nächsten punkt
nämlich fitness theorie der achtung als
trieb während jacob ihr den gefühls
aspekt den phänomenalen gehalt
betrachtete betrachtet wichtig ihr den
motivationen gehalt aber auch noch mehr
diesen einheits gehalt der achtung
in seiner in seinem versuch einer kritik
aller offenbarung und zwar in der
zweiten auflage von 17 93 hatte wie wir
alle wissen fichte einen neuen
paragraphen zugefügt nämlich über die
theorie des willens als vorbereitung
einer reduktion der religion überhaupt
mit diesem neu hinzugekommen paragrafen
da bietet er sich ganz ausführlich der
800 gibt eine theorie der achtung nicht
sagen würde versucht die bei kant etwas
ja hätte etwas verschiedenartig
angelegten merkmale der achtung wenig
recht auf einen begriff zu bringen sind
besser zu klassifizieren
zunächst einmal sagte dass die tat
dieses gefühl der achtung gleichsam der
punkt ist in welchem die vernünftige um
die sinnliche natur endlicher wesen
innig zusammenfließen
diese theorie hatten auch viele andere
philosophen nach sich die vertreten zb
heiliger in seiner interpretation
beachtung also hier wird allgemein
anerkannt dass achtung eine art von
einheits funktion hatten es seien
vernünftige wirkt das gefühl und hier
liegt es nahe an dieser einheit zu
sprechen
jetzt aber das finde ich noch
interessanter analysiert fichte die
achtung angesichts der urteils tafel der
kritik der reinen vernunft nach
verschiedenen gesichtspunkten lesen
dieses längere zitat vor um das
höchstmögliche lichten bei unseren
weiteren weg zu verbreiten wollen wir
noch über dieses wichtige gefühl den
momenten des urteiles nach reflektieren
es ist nämlich wie eben jetzt werdet
worden erstens der qualität nach eine
positive aktion des inneren sinnes die
aus der vernichtung des sinnlichen
triebes als alleinigen bestimmungsgemäß
des willens mit hinaus einschränkung
derselben entsteht ich habe jetzt hier
schon außerdem bestimmungsgrenze sagt
hier findet sich also auch wieder unter
der hand eine gravierende änderung
er springt spricht jetzt hier immer von
trieb das macht kann in diesem sinn
nicht er spricht zwar von triebfeder
aber diese rede vertriebe ist bei fichte
neue art wie behaupten möchte zweitens
die quantität das ist bedingt bestimmbar
der grad der intention und extension
fähig und beziehungen der willens formen
empirisch bestimmbare wesen auf das
gesetz unbedingt und völlig bestimmt
keiner gerade der intension und
extension fähig achtung schlecht
hingegen die einfache idee des gesetzes
unbedingt und unbestimmter unendlich
gegen das ideal in welchem gesetz und
willens form eines konkretes der
relation nach bezieht sich dieses gefühl
auf dass ich als substanz er wieder im
reinen selbstbewusstsein und wird dann 8
und 2 höheren geistig natur die sich
ästhetisch in gefühle das atmet äußert
oder im empirischen den abstieg
konkurrenz unserer besonderen wild vom
mit dem gesetz selbst zufrieden vor sich
selbst oder auf das gesetz als grund
unserer verbindlichkeit achtung
schlechthin das gefühl des notwendigen
primats des gesetzes und unseren
notwendigen support dazu hunderte senden
oder und zwar jetzt drittens die
relationen auf das gesetz als substanz
gedacht und signal endlich der
modernität nach ist acht unmöglich gegen
empirisch bestimmt nicht gewesen
wirklich gegen das sind gesetzt und
notwendig gegen das allein heilige
gewesen wir sehen also hier findet ein
versucht mit hilfe von kantischen
kategorien urteils formen diese theorie
der achtung zu begreifen die kant an
vielen stellen angedeutet hatte aber ich
sehe ja disparat gelassen hatte und hier
ist der versuch ordnung in diese
disparitäten zu bringen
ja und jetzt sehen wir hier das wichtig
immer mehr den begriff des triebes ins
spiel bringt um die achtung zu bestimmen
insofern nun dieses gefühl der achtung
den willen als empirisch vermögen
bestimmt und wieder im wollen durch
selbsttätigkeit bestimmbar ist als zu
welchem prüfe wie ein solches gefühl uns
aufsuchen mussten heißt es trieb trieb
aber eines wirklichen wollens kann es da
kein wollen ohne selbstbewusstsein der
freiheit möglich ist nur durch beziehung
auf das ich wirklich nur in der form der
selbstachtung seien auch bei kant hatten
wir gesehen dass achtung in letzer
hinsicht nicht die achtung für eine
person ist einer anderen person obwohl
kann immer wieder beispiele bringt
dieses gemeinen mannes der sich
anständig verhält und hinsichtlich
dessen ich gar nicht umhin kommen um
achtung zu verspüren aber kannte hatte
gesagt achtung ist eigentlich letzte
hinsicht selbstachtung aber nicht als
individuum sein als unsere höhere
bestimmungen uns also die vernunft
bezieht sich letztendlich auf sich
selbst und auch das scheint hier
wichtige noch mal zu sagen es geht und
die selbstbezüglichkeit diese in der
achtung die darin angelegtes jetzt aber
als trainer jetzt gibt es noch ein
weiteres werk nicht nur den zweiten
paragrafen dieser suche der kritik an
offenbar unser leben auch in seinem
system sittenlehre das dem fünf jahre
später erschien und hier vor einem
zweiten hauptstück über die reduktion
der realität und anwendung des prinzips
der sittlichkeit hier wird jetzt die
achtung noch stärker trieb theoretisch
und faltet und zwar als sittlicher trieb
oder vor dem gesichtspunkt des südlichen
trieb es er sagt der natur trip geht auf
aus auf etwas materials lediglich um der
materie will auf genuss und des genusses
der reine trieb auf absolute
unabhängigkeit des handelns als eines
solchen von jenem triebe auf freiheit
und freiheit wenn der kausalität hat
zulässt vorläufig dieses sich nicht
anders denken als das zur folge dass
irgend los nicht geschehe was die natur
trieb fordern
so nah dass aus ihm bloß und lediglich
eine unterlassung aber gar keine
positive handlung folgen können außer
der inneren handlung der
selbstbestimmung und jetzt kommt dieses
diese achtung trieb theoretischen spiel
ich sehe mich als freisetzen können der
reflexion wird durch den ok oben
schrieben betrieb der sich an das
subjekt des hilflos richtig gefordert
ich soll so nach meine freiheit
allerdings setzen als etwas positives
als grund einer wirklichen hand und
keineswegs etwa einer bloßen
unterlassung also ich das reflektieren
das soll eine gewisse bestimmung des
willens auf mich als das schwimmende zu
beziehen
dieses wollen lediglich aus der
selbstbestimmung abzuleiten genötigt
zahlen das zu beziehen wollen ins zu
nachmittags wahrnehmbares objektiv ist
uns aber alles objektive kommt man nur
zu als ziemlichen und naturwesen durch
das bloß objektivieren mit objektivieren
werden wir uns selbst in diese sphäre
gesetzt und jetzt kommt mit mit
besonderer bedacht der sittliche trieb
ins spiel sagt dazu folgendes der
sittliche trieben ist ein gemischter
trieb er hat von der natur trieben das
material worauf ergeht das heißt der mit
ihrem synthetisch vereinigte und ihn
einst verschmolzen natur trägt geht auf
dieselbe handlung auf welche gleichfalls
geht wenigstens zu teilen die form aber
hat er lediglich zum reinen trinkt er
ist absolut wieder reine und volk etwas
schlechthin ohne allen zweck aus ihm
selbst geht absolut nicht auf irgend ein
genuss aus von welcher art auch seinen
zweck alles dessen was erfordernis
gänzlich unabhängigkeit
aber welches ist dann wieder der zweck
dieser gänzlich unabhängigkeit war ein
genuss
oder dass etwas schlechterdings nicht
sie ist ihr eigener zweck soll
beabsichtigt werden schlechthin weil sie
soll weil ich ich bin innere
zufriedenheit die man auf gelegen sein
empfindet ist etwas zufälliges also
jetzt geht es um den täglichen betrieb
der eine gewisse synthese darstellt von
natur trieb und rhein trieb und meine
these ist jetzt das
die achtung als sittlichen trieb diesem
sinne debütierte eben auch eine einheit
aus diesen beiden bereichen natur und
diese rein vernunft zu leisten vermag
betrieb entsteht nicht aus ihr sondern
sie vielmehr entsteht aus dem triebe
kündigt sich an der achtung und seine
bevölkerung oder nicht bevölkerung ihre
billigung oder missbilligung das gefühl
der zufriedenheit mit sich selbst oder
der peinigen ssten selbstverachtung erst
positiv tritt an irgendeinem bestimmten
handeln
er ist allgemein und bezieht sich auf
alle mögliche freien handlung auf jede
äußerung des naturtrübes zu bewusstsein
kommt nach der oben scharf angegebenen
grenzt selbstständig gibt sich selbst
jedes mal seinen zweck aufgeht aus auf
eine absolute kausalität und steht mit
dem natur triebe in wechselwirkung in
dem er von ihnen die materie aber auch
nur solche die und keineswegs als ein zu
verfolgen den zweck erhält und von einer
seite die ihm die form gibt endlich der
gebiete kategorisch das erfordert wird
als irgendwie nicht gefordert also
dieses tägliche trieb der bedarf sowohl
in einer gewissen hinsicht eine
wechselwirkung mit dem natur trieb um
nämlich von ihm die materie also eine
gewisse kraft so würde ich es nennen
bekommt und dann taucht natürlich auch
die orientierung ihr dass die judikative
moment was er vom reinen trieb bekommt
so jetzt komme ich schon zum schluss
also meine these ist dass jakob und
fichte versuchen das komplexe phänomene
achtung nach kant weiter zu analysieren
und jeweils in eine bestimmte richtung
aufzulösen
nach jakob ist die achtung nur ein
phänomen welches sich in folge bestimmte
kognitive update einstellt muss noch hin
zu sagen hinzufügen achtung ist bei
jakob ein gefühl was viel weiter ist als
bei kant bekannt die achtung sich nur
auf moralische sachverhalte bezieht wer
nach jakob die achtung geben auch auf
intellektuelle leistungen sich beziehen
kann diese was die
duell tugenden betrifft die aber auch
irgendwelche besonders verständigen
vermögen betrifft die kante jetzt nicht
als streng moralischer klassifizieren
würde also einen viel weiteren griff
nach fichte hingegen ist die achtung ein
trieb der die vernünftigste einheit des
menschen in seiner freien moralischen
handlung bewirkt und dadurch auch eine
gewisse these darstellt zwischen dem
natur trieb den materialen trieb und dem
reinen vernünftigen trieb